The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So I'd
like to continue with what
we were discussing last time.
We were at the point where
we're discussing the three
dimensional wave equation.
Before we start,
let me take care
of a couple of
administrative things.
So for one, I'm very close to
finishing grading the quizzes.
So as soon as I do,
I'll put them on a DHL
and ship them back to Boston.
Of course, those of you
who are in Singapore
will get them from--
locally.
And so that's done.
The quiz solution, of
course, has been posted.
You must have seen it by now.
So I would encourage you
to go over this solution.
It was a pretty good problems,
actually, both of them
were pretty good.
And the other
thing I want to say
is that I have posted
the new homework.
So has anybody looked at it yet?
OK, if you look at
it, it might appear
to be a little bit
intimidating, especially
the graduate version.
It is about six or seven pages.
But you may know from experience
that if your homework is
very wordy, it means
that most of the work
has been done for you.
So basically, what
I've done is I've--
the reason I-- this is the first
time I give this assignment.
And basically I
develop the analogy
between the optical Hamiltonian
and the mechanical Hamiltonian.
And I guide you through a
few derivations, a few proofs
that basically, I think, in my
opinion, elucidate the analogy
and the difference.
Of course, they're
not exactly the same.
OK, and the reason I did
it is because last year was
the first time that they
taught the Hamiltonian.
It used to be--
I used to just skip that
part and do other things.
But last year I did it.
And I got some
pretty good feedback
from the students who thought
that, well, you know, this
is kind of a cool analogy.
So this year I
expanded it a bit.
So that's why this homework
is a little bit rich.
But it's not to bad, really,
once you get into it.
And if you follow the
instructions carefully,
each equation should taken
no more than two lines.
So it is not like a long
derivation or [INAUDIBLE]
or anything like that.
It's just a step by
step, and if you--
but read it carefully.
Because there's some
derivatives involved.
So you will want to make sure
you take the correct derivative
each time.
That's the only challenge.
If you can manage to
do it, which you will,
if you follow the
instructions carefully,
then it should be painless.
And there's a little bit of
MATLAB that you have to do.
But that's not valuable.
And the code, actually the
MATLAB that you have to do,
I also give you the code.
It's posted to the website.
It's a bunch of functions.
And one of the things that
I do in the assignment
is I walk you through how
to use the MATLAB code.
So what you will have
to do, basically,
is take one of the
functions and modify it.
Yeah, someone, turn on the mic.
Have a question?
Or-- OK.
So going back to the--
I think there's a question.
Somebody has turned on your
mic, which is OK, actually,
as long as you
don't say anything
embarrassing to [INAUDIBLE].
So let me go back.
Let's go back now
to the main topic.
So, of course, we have
moved on from Hamiltonians
and all that stuff.
We're doing wave optics now.
And the last time we
discussed the wave equation.
And without really a proof--
we did the proof of the
one dimensional case.
But then without the
proof, I just added.
Basically, the one
dimensional case
was this one, just the
derivative of the Z term
without any additional terms.
And then you can think
of it simply by symmetry.
If you accept that 3D
space is symmetric,
then the way you go
from one dimension
into the three
dimensions is by just
adding two derivatives
similar to the one
that you already had.
And, of course, the waves
that we'll get in 3D
are much richer than the waves
that we expected to get in 1D.
And here I plotted two cases.
One is a plane wave, which
I will play the movie.
So you will see the
fringes, in this case,
of the plane wave are moving in
some arbitrary direction now.
It can go anywhere in 3D.
Of course, I can
only show a slice
on the plane of your projector.
And there's a spherical wave
where the wavefronts are not
circles as you see here.
But they're actually spheres.
So they're spheres
that are propagating
clearly outwards in this case.
So this is what we used to call
it a diverging spherical wave
in geometrical optics.
Well, you can also
have the opposite.
You can have a
converging spherical wave
if the wavefronts
are moving inwards.
So one of these are valid
solutions to the wave equation.
And the plane wave
is very simple.
I will do it next.
The spherical wave is
not really difficult,
but it involves a transformation
of the coordinates
from cartesian that
we have here to polar.
And this is done in the book.
I'm not going to
do it in the class.
It is a little bit of work.
And you don't get any
particular intuition.
If you take a class
in electromagnetics
or electrostatics, they
will probably do it.
But because in
this class, we will
use the spherical wave in its
full form very radically--
we'll use an
approximation to it.
That's why I don't bother
to do the full derivation.
OK, I'm going to skip
now a couple of slides.
And I'm going to go directly
to this one, slide number 16,
which is the plane wave.
So what I would like to do--
so, for the rest of the class
now, pretty much for the next,
what is it, seven or eight
weeks that we have left?
We will be talking
almost exclusively
about plane waves and
their superpositions.
Because what we will discover
is that we can describe
every optical wave and--
well, at least within
the approximations
that are valid in this class--
you can describe
every optical wave
as a superposition
of plane waves.
It's a very powerful property.
Because plane waves, as we
will see, they're very simple.
And they obey some relatively
straightforward properties.
So if we learn how to
describe those properly,
then we can describe a great
variety of other phenomena,
including diffraction,
interference, refraction,
and a number of other things.
So I would like to make sure
that we understand plane waves.
It is a crucial
part of the class.
OK, so in the last lecture,
we wrote a simple wave
that we'll call
the harmonic wave.
And it used to look like this.
From now on, I will start
using a phasor notation almost
without warning.
So when I start throwing
complex exponentials,
you know that I'm
using the phasor.
OK, so having said
that, now let's
look at the phasor of
what I wrote last time.
So last time I wrote something
that looked like e to the ikz
e to the minus i omega t.
And I call this a harmonic wave.
So this was in 1D.
So the plane wave is basically
the generalization of this one.
Now, I'm going to have to write
terms of the form y and x.
Do you remember what
we call the quantity k
in the case what I still had
the one dimensional wave?
What was the name of k?
AUDIENCE: It was the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Wave number, sorry, yeah,
wave number, yeah.
I'm sorry, someone answered
in Singapore, so I--
OK, but he was diligent.
So make sure to
push your button.
OK, so k is the wave number.
And it is fair to use it
if you have one dimension.
But if you have
three dimensions,
then we actually need,
at least apparently,
we need three such quantities.
So I need to put the
z subscript here.
And then I need two more,
one for the y and one for x.
So now the triad
of these three--
I don't want to call
them wave numbers.
They're not really wave numbers.
But these three
quantities that have the--
I mean, these are essentially
spatial periods, aren't they,
in the three dimensions?
So these quantities, if you take
the triad of these quantities,
it is called the wave vector.
And it is usually--
we use the same symbol
as the wave number,
but with the vector now.
And it consists of the
three components, ky, kz.
It is a matter of taste
how you write vectors.
In this class, I actually--
I will alternate a little bit.
Sometimes I will write
vectors like this
as a triad in a parenthesis.
Sometimes I might
write the vectors
like this where I
use the unit vector,
the unit Cartesian vectors.
Of course-- OK, I hope
that's not confusing.
One can easily-- clearly
they're both commonly used.
So that quantity k,
then, is the wave vector.
And its significance, you
can see it on the slide.
It's probably better if I
don't attempt to draw it there.
But you can see it on the slide.
So the wavefront
of the plane wave
is a surface which is
perpendicular to the wave
vector.
And what is a wavefront?
Well, wavefront, you
saw it in the movie
that I played earlier.
Wavefront is the surface upon
which the phase of the wave
is constant.
So what is this?
This is basically a three
dimensional sinusoid of which
we only see a 2D slice.
So this is sinusoid
which alternates.
The black regions are
negative, minimum.
I mean they're sort of a
maximum negative value.
The bright stripes are
maximum positive value.
And the wavefront is a surface
on which the phase of the wave
has the same value.
For example, if
the phase is zero,
then we're talking
about the positive peak.
If their phase is pi,
then we're talking
about the negative
trough, and so
on, and so forth, or anywhere
in between, for that matter.
And the wavefront has a
sense of travel to it.
Because if I play
the movie again,
then you can see that these
surfaces of constant phase
are moving.
This is the sense that the wave
transports energy, if you wish.
Because the wavefronts are
moving with the wave speed.
OK, so then we call
it the plane wave,
because this surface is of
constant phase or planes.
Of course, you only
see them as lines here.
Because, again, we're looking
at the slice of the wave.
But in 3D, they
would be actually
planes that would be propagating
with the speed of the wave.
So that is-- so then
the wave vector,
we need it in order
to tell us what
is the orientation
of these planes.
And for reasons
of convenience, we
define it to be perpendicular
to those planes.
Now, that's one
useful thing to know.
But that's not all.
The wave vector, it appears to
be composed of three elements.
So the question is are these--
do I really have
three parameters?
Can I describe a plane
wave with three parameters?
Well, even before I do any math,
you could probably guess that I
shouldn't.
Because these are surfaces.
These are planar
surfaces in 3D space.
So I cannot really fit 3
dimensions of planes in a 3D
space, right?
Something is wrong
with that argument,
even without doing any math.
So in actuality, these three
numbers, kx, ky, and kz,
they have to be related somehow.
I cannot arbitrarily
define all three of them.
But I have to
somehow relate them.
So the way I relate
them is I actually
go back to my wave equation.
And recall this
thing here, the wave,
which I will call it something.
What did I call it?
I didn't call it
anything, actually.
I just put an amplitude
coefficient in front.
So the amplitude coefficient,
it is good for completeness,
I guess.
And it must satisfy
the wave equation.
So it must satisfy--
I'll call it something
now, because--
f, I guess.
So it is f of x, y, z, t.
And it must satisfy
this nasty thing, which
looks like df dx squared plus
df dy squared plus df dz squared
minus 1 over the velocity now,
d squared f over dt squared.
It must equal to 0.
This is what we call
the wave equation.
And for future
reference, sometimes,
instead of writing all
these deduced derivatives,
there's a shorthand
which collapses
all of this with a symbol del.
So you can just
write del squared
f minus 1 over c squared
df dt squared is 0.
OK, that's the wave equation.
Very good, so now
what I need to do
is I need to plug this
expression into the wave
equation.
So what expression?
This expression that
I had for the wave,
I need to put it
into the equation.
OK, almost by inspection, we
can see what's going to happen.
So we have an
exponential, right?
And if I take one derivative,
the first derivative,
it will knock out--
it will multiply by ikx, right,
if I take the x derivative.
If I take the
second x derivative,
it will bring out another ikx.
And since i squared
equals minus 1,
it means that the derivative
will look like this, d--
let me write it separately here.
The second derivative,
for example,
of F with respect
to x squared, it
will equal minus kx squared
times f itself, right?
And then it can do the
same for y, and z, and t.
Except in the case of time, I
will pull out omega squared.
So if I substitute all of that
now and I put it in, I will get
that minus kx squared minus
ky squared minus kz squared--
these are the first
batch of derivatives--
and then minus omega squared--
but I have to divide by c also
because c, actually, c squared
is in the wave equation.
So all of this, according to the
wave equation, must equal to 0.
And, of course, it is
possible to satisfy this
by setting f equal to 0.
But that's not very interesting.
So basically what this means,
that this quantity here, it
must equal to 0.
So then, as advertised, the
three parameters, kx, ky, kz,
they're not independent.
But I can specify two of them.
The third one is completely
determined by the two
among the three plus the
frequency of the wave.
So if I give you
omega, kx, and ky,
then this equation will force
kz to have a certain value.
And you can see from
this equation, which
is written bottom of the
whiteboard and on the slide--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh,
oh, oh, oh, thank you,
thank you, yes,
because I have a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yes, thank you.
Because I have a
minus sign here.
So the extra minus will
become a plus here.
Yes, OK, now it is correct.
And so if you look at
this equation now, what
does it describe?
If you think of kx, ky, kz,
if you think of them now
as a new three
dimensional space,
what is the surface
that the three of them
are constrained to lie upon?
Button.
AUDIENCE: A spherical shell?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: It's
a sphere, that's right,
a shell, the shell
of a sphere, yeah.
And this sphere is not new
to us who have seen it.
It actually popped up
in a different context.
We called it the
Descartes sphere.
It is actually the
same sphere that--
actually not even
Descartes, an Arab scientist
in the 11th century,
guessed from Snell's law.
So it is a little bit, I
guess, magical, or soothing,
or rewarding, whatever
combination of those
adjectives you like, that we
found a nice analogy-- or not
analogy, actually,
we found an agreement
with geometrical optics.
In geometrical optics, we said
that the radius of this sphere
equals 2 pi upon lambda.
This is now what,
in our new language,
we call it the wave number,
times the index of refraction,
n.
Now this is something that
I haven't told you yet.
But I will tell you later today.
In this equation, I
haven't said anything
about index of refraction.
However, we know, again
from geometrical optics,
that c, the speed
of light, depends
on the index of refraction.
So another way to derive
this equation is to say--
to put the free space
speed of light over here.
And then in order for the
equation to be correct,
I would have to
multiply by n squared,
the index of refraction.
So you can see from
this that, indeed,
the radius of the sphere.
Oh, and of course, to compute
the radius of this sphere,
I have to use, once again,
these dispersion relations.
So the radius of
this sphere, if you
look from this equation over
here, the radius of this sphere
is k, the magnitude
of the wave vector.
It must equal n omega
over c free space.
OK, and now it is a
matter of preference
how you want to do it.
For example, you can
write omega as 2 pi times
nu, where nu is
of the frequency.
Remember, omega is the
angular frequency--
over cfs.
Then you can use the
dispersion relation,
which says that c free
space equals lambda nu.
So nu will cancel.
And you end up with n times
2 pi over lambda free space.
And, of course, nu--
I don't say anything
about free space,
because nu is the
same everywhere,
whether it is free
space, or a slave--
I mean, not free space.
I'm sorry.
OK, so that's where this
equation comes from.
That's why the radius
of the k sphere,
it equals n omega
over the free--
over the speed of light
in a vacuum or 2 pi
n over lambda, the
wavelength in free space.
Now, those of you--
some of you may have
taken solid state.
This k sphere also
comes up there.
And it is called
the Ewald sphere.
In our language in optics, we
seldom call it Ewald sphere.
We call it k sphere
or Descartes sphere.
But all of these three terms,
all of these three names,
they actually denote
the same thing.
And, of course, in the
case of solid state,
this sphere does not
apply to light usually.
But it applies to what?
Button?
AUDIENCE: Electrons.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: To
electrons, that's correct.
So according to
quantum mechanics,
electrons are also waves.
And they satisfy-- actually that
don't satisfy this equation.
They satisfy the
Schroedinger equation,
which is in one of the
problems of the homework.
So anyway, so
Schroedinger equation
similarly leads to a
sphere like this one.
Is there one thing that--
OK, so this is a sort of
preliminary introduction
to plane waves.
One thing that I would like
to very strongly emphasize
is this expression over here,
the complex exponential--
I will rewrite it once again.
e to the i kx x plus ky y
plus kz z minus omega t,
OK, this expression,
when we see that,
when we see an exponential
with linear terms
in the Cartesian coordinates,
that's a plane wave.
And now you know why, right?
Because it corresponds
to this moving wavefront.
And, of course,
most of the time,
we will not add it like this.
We will omit this term
because of the phasor business
that we discussed last time.
So we will actually
see it like this.
And also, very often, when--
several things that
happen in here.
For one thing, these three
numbers, as I said before,
they're not free.
So they are given by kx
squared plus ky squared plus kz
squared equals omega
over c squared or--
OK.
This is another way
of solving the sphere.
So we will see these
kinds of expressions.
For example, I might
write something like e
to the i kx x plus ky y plus.
And there's a z here
outside of the square root.
So this looks a
little bit scary.
But it doesn't need to be scary.
It a plane wave.
And we will see expressions like
this one later in the class.
But I want to sort
of prepare you now
so that they are associated
with a physical meaning
in your minds.
It is not just an expression.
It's actually
denotes a plane wave.
The two linear terms here--
actually, all three are
linear. x, y, and z
appear as first powers.
And the reason this
square root appears here
is because of the Descartes
sphere, or the Ewald sphere,
or whichever.
OK, any questions
about plane waves?
The other wave that we'll
be dealing with quite a bit
is the spherical wave.
And so clearly, as the name
suggests, in this case,
you have spherical wavefronts,
which are either going away
from a source, a diverging wave,
or inwards, a converging wave.
Just as an aside,
by the way, I should
emphasize that the spherical
wave is not a physical thing.
So plane wave is not
physical either, by the way.
Why is the plane
wave not physical?
I mean, what's an obvious
reason why a plane wave must be
an approximation of something?
Button.
AUDIENCE: Energy of the
plane wave is infinite.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
It has infinite energy.
It is infinitely large.
So, clearly, I cannot
create plane waves per se.
I can only create sort of finite
approximations to plane waves.
A spherical wave is--
but nevertheless, it is
an interesting thing.
And the reason we spend
all this time defining it
is because it provides a lot
of mathematical convenience
in dealing with more
realistic waves, waves
that can be realized.
I can express them in terms
of this fictitious entity,
the plane wave.
The same is true for
the point source,
but for a slightly
different reason.
It is actually impossible to
create an ideal spherical wave.
The best thing you can do is
you can create a wave that
would sort of, if you--
well, the only-- the best
thing that you can do
is you can create a
dipole source here.
So if you aim the
dipole the same,
the vertical direction,
then what you can do
is you can create a
radiation pattern that
has approximately 60, or
actually, 120 degrees opening,
126, to be--
63, isn't it?
I think it's 63
degrees, the dipole.
Anyway, so you can create a
direction pattern like this,
but never quite
a spherical wave.
In fact, someone as
famous as Einstein
said that spherical
waves don't exist.
Nevertheless, it is
a very convenient
mathematical quantity.
And that's why
we're describing it.
But again, by the way, this
is true in any kind of physics
that you might learn.
For example, in
mechanics, very often
you deal with frictionless--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Is [INAUDIBLE]??
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Suppose you burst a
small cracker in a water tank?
Then it wouldn't--
wouldn't it be?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh, I'm
sorry, I meant only in optics.
AUDIENCE: Optics.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yeah, in water tank,
possibly you can create
a spherical wave.
Even so, it's not
Because it is finite, right?
It has a finite source.
Anyway, the reason in optics
you can fundamentally not
create this kind of thing is
because of charge conservation.
You cannot-- in order to create
a spherical wave like this,
you would have to create
an oscillating charge here.
And no such thing exists.
So the only thing you can do
is you can create a dipole.
That is two charges which are
alternating, up and down, up
and down, positive and negative.
That would result in a wave
that it looks approximately
like a spherical wave, but only
in the direction perpendicular
to the dipole.
In the direction along
the dipole axis, it
actually, the wave vanishes.
So it is very different
than a spherical wave.
To justify it a little bit why,
even though it is non-physical,
why we spend so much
time discussing it,
it has to do, actually,
with systems theory.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't a dipole
actually canceling out
because of the distance between
the top and bottom source?
You have like a different
distance between them.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: The
charge, the charge is 0.
The charge is 0.
But you still have
a dipole moment.
Then moreover, if the dipole
is oscillating, that is,
if it is going from
positive to negative,
positive to negative
very, very fast, then you
have charges accelerating.
So therefore you generate
electromagnetic radiation,
as we will see in a little bit.
AUDIENCE: No, no, I
mean the intensity
of the field from the
dipole isn't necessarily
vanishing along the axis if the
spacing's set the right way.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Not
everywhere along the axis,
but you will definitely
get nulls along the axis.
If I remember correctly,
yeah, the dipole
has a radiation pattern
that looks like this.
It looks like a butterfly.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but it's
dependent on the distance
between the plus and
the minus charges.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
No, I'm talking
about an infinitesimally
small dipole now.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yeah, if you
have like a lambda
over four and 10
or something like
that, then yes,
the radiation pattern
looks different.
But in the simplest possible
case that you can approximate
the best spherical wave is an
infinitesimally small dipole
whose radiation pattern
looks like a butterfly.
So we actually went a little
bit ahead of ourselves now.
Because this entire
discussion, it
involved electromagnetics,
which we haven't done yet.
But by the end of
this lecture, it
will be a little
bit more clear what
I mean by dipoles and
all of these things.
The thing I meant to say
is that the spherical wave,
mathematically, it
corresponds to a point source.
And that is something that
most of you, probably,
at some point or another,
took a class on linear systems
where typically you learn a
term called an impulse response.
So the impulse pulse
in the time domain
is a very narrow excitation.
In fact, it is
infinitesimally narrow.
And it is so narrow
that, because it
has to carry finite energy, it
also has infinite amplitude.
That's what it's
called an impulse.
So the spherical wave is
the equivalent of that,
but in space now.
The spherical wave originates
as an infinitesimally small
disturbance, if you wish, which
then mathematically creates
this uniformly or isotropically
expanding spherical wavefront.
And from that point of
view, it is very useful.
Because even the dipole
that I said before,
it can be described,
actually, as a superposition
of a spherical wave.
So I can be physically correct
if I do my physics correct.
I can get the proper answer.
So the spherical wave provides
this mathematical convenience.
Also, to be honest, the
math that we will do here,
it is a very good
approximation to what
you observe in the laboratory.
That's another good
justification for using it.
Because even though
we know that there
is no such thing
as a point source,
many of the things that we
will derive in the next two
lectures based in this sort
of crude approximation,
they tend now to be very
good approximations for what
you see in the laboratory.
For example, if
you take a pinhole,
a pinhole is a
finite thing, right?
I mean, the smallest
pinhole that people
use in the laboratory, it may
have a diameter of one micron.
Sometimes we use bigger,
three, five micron,
something like that.
Well, if you pass light
through a pinhole,
the light that comes out is,
to a very good approximation,
described by a spherical wave,
but of course not everywhere,
right?
The light coming
out of a pinhole,
it doesn't come out backwards.
It only goes forward, right?
So therefore, you have-- you
know, clearly, the expression
is approximately
correct, but only
for the part of the wave,
the portion that is physical.
So we have to be a little
bit mindful of what
is the meaning of everything
that we write down,
especially when things
like that are involved.
The spherical wave
has another problem.
It has the problem that
it blows up at the center.
And the reason it
blows up is because--
well, like the impulse
in the time domain
that you learned in
linear dynamical systems,
it has to have a finite energy.
So in this context
here, the finite energy,
as you proved in the
homework some time ago,
it means that the amplitude
of this spherical wave
must decrease like
one over the distance.
So this 1 over r that we get
in the denominator, of course,
at r equals 0, it
explodes, right?
So, again, that is the delta
function, the impulse analogy.
So the spherical wave has a
few mathematical inconveniences
of this sort that we
have to be mindful with.
Now, there's one more
mysterious thing about it,
which I will just point out.
And I will then move
on without saying why.
If you look at the expression
of the spherical wave--
let me write it down.
It looks like cosine kr
minus omega t over r.
And let's take stock here.
So the 1 over r we discussed.
The 1 over r is
energy conservation.
We always like that.
The cosine that you
see in the numerator,
if I go back and play the
movie of the spherical wave,
we have to wait for the
plane wave to finish here.
So the kr minus omega
t, it is this sort
of explosion of the wavefronts
that you see in the movie.
So kr, if i is the radius, kr
describes this sphere again.
So the cosine kr
basically tells you
that you have these alternating
positive and negative
valued spheres.
And the minus omega t
is the traveling aspect.
It tells you that
these spheres explode.
They propagate outwards
as a function of time.
So this is the meaning
of the kr minus omega t.
Then it bothers to put
another term over there,
minus pi over 2.
And this might sound
a little bit weird.
I mean, in general, you can put
any phase that you like there.
It means that you have
a shifted time axis.
So I could put 5 there.
Why did they bother
to put pi over 2?
What is the pi
over 2 relative to?
OK, it turns out if you properly
solve Maxwell's equations,
which we haven't
seen yet, but I'm
sure you are aware that
there is such a thing called
Maxwell's equation
that describes
electromagnetic waves.
OK, so if you solve it properly
with this kind of point source,
because of something having
to do with magnetic fields,
you pick up a phase delay
with respect to what?
You pick up a phase delay
with respect to the source.
So this is now really weird.
It tells you if you have a
source that is oscillating,
let's say, like a cosine, so
it is maximum at t equals 0,
the wave that comes out
will actually be a sine.
So it will be phase
shifted by pi over 2.
There's no easy way to explain
this either than solving
Maxwell's equation.
There is actually some papers in
the literature-- this is very,
very interesting for an--
I don't know.
it's strange, right?
It can be explained
from the equation,
but it's still a
little bit strange.
So people are actually
working on this phase shift.
There's some very
strange aspects to it.
Anyway, for us, the phase
shift, we'll just accept it.
It is well established.
So we'll just accept
it and move on.
When we write it
as a phasor, I mean
in the complex
presentation, of course,
e to the minus i pi
over 2 is minus i.
So I skipped a few
steps of the slide.
So let me do them
on the whiteboard.
So to go from this in
the complex presentation,
you would write e to the i, kr
minus omega t minus pi over 2.
And, of course, you still
have this thing outside.
Nothing can-- this
is not affected.
OK, then remember
that e to the minus
i pi over 2 equals minus i.
And it equals 1 over i.
So this is why the i appeared
in the denominator over here.
So because pi over
2 is kind of a pain
to write down, when we
write the spherical way,
we'll just write it with
the i in the denominator.
And this i is actually not--
I mean, it's not a
big deal, you know.
If you-- in fact, myself,
sometimes I will just skip it.
But it's kind of nice
to know that it's there.
And, of course, in
the-- the other thing
that we'll do
commonly, but by now
a thing where we're
comfortable with that
is that we neglect the
temporal variation.
And then we'll get the phasor.
The last thing that we'll do
before moving on to a slightly
different topic is--
remember in
geometrical optics, we
derived a lot of
useful things using
this paraxial approximation.
So the paraxial approximation
basically says that--
in this case, the wave
originated relatively far away.
And you have these
spherical wavefronts
which are nice spheres
near the source.
But if you go at a relatively
long distance, basically,
you cannot tell the difference
between these spherical
wavefronts and parabolas.
And it turns out that,
because the sphere involves
this nasty square
root, it is much more
convenient to represent
this as parabolas.
So the way you go from the
sphere to the parabola,
I did it on the slide.
And I will do it again.
Because this is a
derivation I want
you to be very familiar with.
We've done it a few times.
And we'll do it again and again.
You start with the
expression for the wave.
So it is e to the ikr, right?
And there is bells and whistles.
There is all the r's.
There's the i's.
Let me just write this.
OK, and then remember,
so we have r.
This is the polar coordinate.
So it is x plus
y plus z squared.
And the paraxial approximation--
let me put this back--
in our convention, usually,
is that this is the z-axis.
So z is the axis of
propagation, the optical axis.
And then you have the other
two axes perpendicular to it.
Typically, we'll denote
x as being vertical.
OK, and is this now right
handed, the way I did it?
Yeah, right hand, OK good.
All right, so the
paraxial approximation
then means that z is much
bigger than the values
of the other two coordinates.
Because, basically,
I'm limiting myself
to operate in this region.
that's the meaning of the
paraxial approximation.
So what you do then is
you do a Taylor expansion
on this square root.
So you pull z outside.
Then you use the Taylor
property that says 1 plus small
is approximately equal
to 1 plus small over 2.
And then you can
see that r equals
z 1 plus x squared plus y
squared over z squared times 2,
which is also known as z plus--
OK.
So that's the
paraxial approximation
for the polar variable.
And now I can, of course,
put it in my expression.
So this means that e to the
ikr is approximately equal
to e to the ikz, e to the ik, x
squared plus y squared over 2z.
And sometimes we will
leave it like this.
Or sometimes, we will remember
that k equals 2 pi upon lambda.
And then this expression
now becomes e to the i 2 pi
z upon lambda.
e to the i, notice
what will happen.
The 2s will cancel.
A pi will remain.
And you'll get--
OK.
So all of these are
interchangeable expressions
that we can use for
spherical waves.
Another interesting question--
I omitted something.
I omitted 1 over ir.
And actually, there's
also the amplitude.
Let's put the amplitude
for completeness.
What happens to the ir?
Should they also do some
paraxial approximation over it?
It turns out it is sufficient
to simply approximate it as z.
For the part that appears
outside of the exponent,
we can simply
approximate it as z.
And the reason is because r,
it is actually slowly varying.
You know, if you compare--
what is r?
Let's see if we can use the--
yeah, so r is this, right?
So if you compare--
OK, so basically, you have
to pick z equals constant.
So I have to pick
a plane that is
tangential to the
sphere at this place.
So I compare r1 to r2, right?
So r1 goes all the way to the
plane. r2 simply stops here.
So think about it this way.
Let's say that the
error that they make--
when I say z is
approximately equal to r,
let's say that they
make a small error.
Let's say that they
make an error of 1%.
That means that they
misrepresent the amplitude
of the wave by 1%.
Now, let's look at the term
that is inside the exponential,
e to the i pi xy, x squared
plus y squared over lambda z.
If I miss by 1%, that is,
if I had e to the 1,000 pi
and I miss by 1%, then it means
I went to e to the 990 pi,
right?
So this 1% error
actually caused me,
how many, 10 full oscillations.
That's why you have to
keep a better approximation
inside the exponential than
I can afford to keep outside.
So with the phase, I have to
be much more accurate in order
to make sure that I don't make
a big error in the phase delay.
And that's because the
cosine varies very rapidly.
As you increase r, the
cosine is oscillating.
But 1 over r is a slowly,
what we call a slowly varying
function of r.
And therefore, we can afford
to be sloppier with it,
if you wish.
So the paraxial approximation,
then, for the spherical wave
is just like that with
z in the denominator
but this additional quadratic
term in the exponent.
And, of course, this
additional quadratic term
is the one where all of
the action is happening.
And this-- we will see
this later in the class.
And that's the second
important lesson
from today, which is that if
we see an expression which
is quadratic in the
Cartesian coordinates,
we'll call it a spherical wave.
So we went through all
these adventures, I guess,
to arrive at two
very basic waves.
One is the kind of wave in whose
phasor you have linear terms
in the cartesian coordinates.
That we'll call the plane wave.
OK, so if you see
something like this,
it doesn't really matter
what these things are, kx,
ky, and so on.
But because these terms
are linear, it is plane.
When you arrive at an
expression that looks like this,
you might have
all kinds of junk.
And somewhere you have something
of the form e to the i pi
x squared plus y
squared over lambda z,
this quadratic means that it is
spherical, or, more accurately,
the paraxial approximation
to a spherical wave.
Yes, button.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what
would be the propagation
of an evanescent wave?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Let's
postpone that for a little bit
later.
That's a good question.
But we don't have the tools
to deal with that yet.
[INAUDIBLE] is asking--
I wrote this square root here.
Here it is.
[INAUDIBLE] is asking,
what if I pick kx and ky
so that the argument of the
square root becomes negative?
Therefore, this quantity
would become imaginary, right?
That is called an
evanescent wave.
But let's not go into it now.
Yeah, we'll come
back to it though.
It's a valid question.
And other questions?
Or I should say, any questions
that I'm willing to answer?
Because that is a
good question, but--.
OK, did you come up with any
questions about spherical waves
or plane waves during the break?
AUDIENCE: OK, here
I have one question.
So just now we mentioned
that when the kx, ky is
very small while the kz is very
big, we call it plane wave,
correct?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Not quite.
It is true, actually,
what you say.
kx and ky will be very small.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, at--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
this one I'm talking
about in the k dimension.
How about in the space,
in the real 3D space.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK, the
paraxial approximation, I
did actually in space.
So this diagram over here,
that was space, x, y, z.
But what you say is true
in the spherical wave.
The reason I'm reluctant
to admit what you say
is because the spherical
wave is not a plane wave.
So therefore kx, ky, kz, they
vary across the wavefront,
right?
So it's a bit more
complicated what happens.
But yeah, if you took a small
portion of the wavefront here,
and you plotted kx--
well, this is the direction.
If you plotted, kz would be big.
And then kx would be very small.
So it is true. kx and
ky are also very small.
But you have to be careful
with a spherical wave.
Because, for example, here,
we have a different kx and kz,
right?
So what it means
here, kx and ky--
well, what does it mean?
Let's not go into Wigner
distributions, right?
OK, so let me say
what I'm trying
to say in plain language.
The kx, ky, kz will define
them for a plane wave.
So a plane wave is this kind
of thing, where you have
a well-defined wave vector.
And the entire
wavefront is planar.
Now, what you are
saying is that if I
have a spherical wavefront
like this, locally,
I can define normals, right?
And I can call those
wave vectors as well.
And that is actually true.
But they're not plane waves.
You can think of them as rays.
That's a good approximation.
They would be the equivalent
of geometrical rays,
but not plane waves.
But nevertheless,
you are correct.
They would-- these
things are also paraxial.
So they would also satisfy
kx, ky much less than kz.
That is true.
Other questions?
I'd like to talk
about a fun topic.
Today, I was-- I want
to do electromagnetics.
So I don't want too spend
too much time on this.
But I'll talk about
it, because it's fun
and very useful
in many contexts.
So in all of this
business, we wrote the--
this is, again,
the wave equation.
But we didn't say anything
about the speed of light.
So actually, we
did a little bit.
I mentioned-- I guess this
is better than a whiteboard.
I have a history of what I've
written throughout the lecture.
Yeah, so at some point,
we did mention this.
We did mention that
the index of refraction
actually enters in this
equation over here.
But if you remember diligently
from your geometrical optics,
the index of
refraction also happens
to be a function of wavelength.
It's not a constant, right?
It is a function of wavelength.
So what is means now is that
in this equation over here,
if I have a single frequency--
now, a single temporal
frequency, a single omega--
then everything is fine.
Because, sure, for this
particular frequency,
I can find the
index of refraction.
And I'm OK.
However, the index of refraction
is a function of wavelength.
And the wavelength, yes, it
is a function of frequency.
We do know that this
equation is true.
But we also said, if you
recall, or if you go back
to the video of
the first lecture
when I first presented this
equation, I gave you a warning.
And I said that this is
the dispersion relation.
But it is not the only
possible dispersion relation.
It is possible to have
waves where the dispersion
relation is different.
OK, first of all,
just to make sure
that the [INAUDIBLE] stuff about
dispersion that we discussed
about the glass, it is true.
In other words, in glass,
yes, the index of refraction
is a function of wavelength.
So this is a plot
that we saw before.
But now, in addition
to that, I'm
talking about a slightly
different type of dispersion.
So this dispersion happens,
for example, in waveguides.
In everything that
we'll do so far,
we sort of assume that
light propagates freely.
We may put some
lenses or whatever,
prisms in the path
of the light, that
is refractors, and
mirrors, and so on.
But all of these are
relatively large.
We never try to confine the
light to a very small space.
But you can do that.
You can create waveguides.
Actually, for visible light, you
will never actually use a metal
here.
You would use a
dielectric waveguide.
But in microwaves, this
is done very commonly.
In microwaves, people trap
the wave in a metal tube
as if it were water, I suppose,
or some kind of a liquid.
You just have a hollow
tube that is a metal.
And then you launch the
microwave inside the tube.
And to give you an idea,
the wavelength in microwaves
is in the order of--
well, as the name suggests,
it is the order of--
the frequency's gigahertz.
So the wavelength should
be between millimeters
and centimeters.
That is typically--
actually, less,
no the wavelength is
a little bit less,
maybe in the order
of millimeters,
typical millimeter.
So the size of these
tubes might also
be on the order of
a few millimeters.
So now you have a guide
that is approximately
of size of a few wavelengths.
So in that case, it turns this
equation, c equals lambda nu,
does not hold anymore.
It is true for a free space.
But it is not true
in a waveguide.
The reason it is not
true in a waveguide
is because the wave must
satisfy boundary conditions.
If you recall when we
gave the wave equation,
we said we would need to
satisfy an initial condition
and boundary conditions.
In free space, there is
no boundary condition.
Actually, there is
a boundary condition
that the wave must
vanish with infinity.
OK, fine, but that doesn't
have any implication
in our calculations.
But, for example, in
the case of a metal,
you have to force the
wave to be 0 on the metal.
Because, well, we'll see
later in electromagnetics
why this is the case.
But take my word for it.
On the metal, the
field must equals 0.
So now if you have a
sinusoid in this metal,
the sinusoid is in
kind of a straitjacket.
Because it is
sinusoidally varying.
But also, it must be
over such a period
that it vanishes at the
edge of the waveguide.
So, for example, it can be--
if this is the waveguide, the
sinusoid can be like this.
That's fine,
because it vanishes.
It can be like this.
That's also fine.
It can be like this, and so on.
But, for example,
can it be like this?
No, that wave cannot.
OK, so I will not do
the full derivation.
And again, it's a little bit--
well, we would have to solve
the partial differential
equation in a serious way.
But it turns out that
this straitjacket
that we put the
light in actually
results in a
different dispersion
relation that looks like this.
It is not the c equals lambda
nu anymore, but it's this one.
AUDIENCE: I have a question?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes?
AUDIENCE: What happens if
a is smaller than lambda?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Then
the wave will not even
get into the waveguide.
It will become evanescent.
So it will not go in.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What is
shown in the diagram,
isn't it a standing wave?
Because it's not--
oscillation is--
the way you have drawn--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah,
it is a standing wave
in the vertical direction.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
how does it propa--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Well,
if the [INAUDIBLE] of it is
bouncing back and forth--
another way to think
of the waveguide
is that the light is--
you can think, actually,
in terms of rays.
You can think of rays
bouncing back and forth.
But you can also have
the conjugate ray.
These are both possible.
And the result is a standing
wave in this sentence.
But you can still
have propagation
on the horizontal axis.
Because there is a component
that goes towards the right.
OK, so when you get an
equation like this one which
relates omega to k-- and, of
course, as you can imagine,
now there's a great
variety of such equations
that you could have.
This is the equation
that happens to be
true for the metal waveguide.
If you replace it with
a different waveguide,
for example, if you
have dielectrics
of different indices here,
then this equation changes.
The bottom line is that if
you have this equation, then
you can plot one of the two.
You have one term here that
is determined by geometry.
a is the size of the guide.
And then you have the wave
vector and the frequency.
And, of course, you have
the free velocity of light.
OK, omega is fundamental.
As soon as you
specify the frequency
of the electromagnetic
wave, nothing
can change that anymore since
we're in the linear region.
But the question is,
what is the wave vector?
So the wave vector
is really what
you are after in this equation.
Omega is given.
It is, say, 10 to the 15 Hertz.
What is the k?
Or in other words,
what is the wavelength?
Now, for reasons which
will become apparent
in a moment, the people who
invented these diagrams,
they actually plot them kind
of the other way around.
Instead of omega on
the horizontal axis,
since omega is given, they put
omega on the vertical axis.
And the horizontal axis is k.
So the way you read this
diagram is-- of course,
you solve this equation.
And the way you read it
is that if I give you
a certain omega, then you have
to draw a horizontal line.
And wherever this horizontal
line meets the plot, this--
you read the abscissa and--
I never get this right.
Is this the abscissa
or the other one?
That's the abscissa?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's the ordinate?
OK.
I must come up with a
mnemonic to remember.
Anyway, so the value
of the horizontal axis
gives you the wave vector,
and hence, the wavelength.
Now, interestingly, if
you were in free space,
this would look like
a straight line.
Because, well, of
course in free space--
I have written this
equation many times.
I don't feel like
writing it again.
In free space-- well,
let me do it once more.
So in free space, I have
that c equals k over 2 pi.
That's also known
as lambda times--
what am I doing?
The other way around--
2 pi over k, that is
also known as lambda,
times omega over 2 pi.
So in free space, then,
you have omega equals ck.
This is an equivalent way of
writing this equation here.
These are basically
the same equation.
So in free space, this
is a straight line.
Now, if you have an
equation like this one,
you can see that at
relatively high frequencies,
they approach.
So, indeed, all of the-- oh, by
the way, what are these curves?
So this equation involves
an integral parameter.
You can plug in--
well, not quite 0, please
erase that from your notes.
I should not have put 0 here.
0 doesn't make sense.
But you can have plus/minus
1, plus/minus 2, and so on.
And these are known as modes.
So the index defines
the mode that
is launched into the waveguide.
So each one of these modes,
at very high frequencies,
it actually kind of approaches
the free space mode.
But as you go to
lower frequencies,
you see that it bends away
and then eventually hits
the ordinate axis.
And there's a gap here now.
Because there's nothing
in this place over here.
So what will happen
if you come up,
if you use an omega that
falls in this range?
AUDIENCE: Evanescent wave.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Correct-- actually, someone
asked it before in Boston.
Someone asked me
before, what happens
if you pick a to be
smaller than a wavelength?
Well, this is what happens.
In fact, I wouldn't espouse
it exactly like this.
A more accurate way
to say it is what
happens if you pick an
omega which is very small?
So therefore, given the value of
a and given the value of omega,
you cannot find the k anymore.
The square root
becomes imaginary.
Well, if that happens, the wave
does not enter the waveguide.
It becomes
evanescent, as we say.
So basically, it may
penetrate a little bit
for a couple of wavelengths.
And then it will
exponentially decay.
Now, if you-- as you
go progressively-- so,
if you launch at
very low frequency,
the wave does not enter.
As you start increasing
the frequency now,
you will see that
the intersection only
meets one mode.
So basically, at the
range of frequencies--
I don't know what it is here.
This looks like 3 or something.
So between-- so the
way you read this axis
is you read the ordinate.
And you multiply by
three times 10 to the 14.
So, for example, 5
actually means 15 times 10
to the 14 Hertz.
OK, so then between
3, the value f3, which
is 9 times 10 to the 14, and
the value, whatever it is, 7,
you only launch one mode.
As you go up in frequency,
if your intersection here
meets more than one
line, then actually you
can have multiple
modes in this guide.
Anyway, so these modes,
these little wiggles
that I drew over
here, the first mode
is the field shape that
looks like this, only half
of the period of the sinusoid.
The next mode, you
allow one full period.
allow 1 1/2 period,
then so on and so forth.
So as you go higher
in frequency,
it means that the wave--
basically, what it means
is that the waveguide now--
or, I should say the
wavelength of the wave
becomes progressively smaller
than the size of the waveguide.
So therefore, you can pack
more modes into the guide.
So I only plotted three here.
Of course, there's infinite.
But anyway, as you
go up in frequency,
you have the possibility to
excite more than one mode.
Now, how do you
excite the modes?
Now, that depends, of course, on
your initial conditions, right?
If you create a
distribution in the entrance
of the waveguide
that looks like this,
then you will excite
the first mode.
If you create a distribution
that looks like this,
well, if the second
mode is allowable,
that is if you are
above the green line,
then you will excite it.
If you are below
the green line, you
will probably excite nothing.
Because the first mode
cannot be excited this way.
The reason I'm telling
you this is not
because I want to do waveguide
theory, but because I
but because I want to do
something that's called a beat.
And a beat is an
extremely useful concept,
both in the space domain
and in the time domain.
So in the time domain,
the beat is actually--
it is a very simple thing.
It is defined as
the superposition
of two sinusoids of slightly
different frequency.
So we said this many times,
that if the wave is linear,
therefore a
superposition is allowed.
If I have two solutions
to the wave equation.
I take the sum.
It is still a solution.
So now what you can
see here very easily--
that's a diagram that I
stole from the textbook.
Because the two waves have
slightly different frequency,
they will misalign.
So you can, for example,
start at the point
where the waves are
exactly aligned.
So they kind of
oscillate together.
When one is positive,
the other is positive.
But because the
period is different,
or the frequency is
different, a little bit later,
they will kind of separate.
And now, over here, you can
see that this is the opposite.
When one of them is positive,
the other is negative.
And if you also happen
to judiciously pick
them to have the
same amplitude, it
means that here when, as we say,
they oscillate out of phase,
it means that the wave amplitude
overall becomes very small.
And so-- and of course,
in the other case,
where they are in
phase, the amplitude
becomes twice the
amplitude of one.
So this is sort of a static
picture from the book.
I also made a movie out of it.
So here you see the
beat propagating.
OK, so now, what is really
interesting about this--
I'm going to play it again.
If you look at it carefully--
it takes a-- let me
play it once more.
Actually, I think I can just--
if you look at it
carefully, you will
see that there is two
different velocities here.
There's two things happening.
One is you have this envelope
that is moving to the right.
But also, inside
the envelope, you
have small fringes, wiggles that
are also moving to the right.
Now, I told you, of course,
but if you look at it once
again more carefully, you
will see that the two are
moving with different speeds.
Can you see it?
The wiggles are moving
faster than the envelope.
And you can see that the
wiggles are moving faster
than the envelop
if you look here
near the vicinity of the null.
You will see that there's
a little bit of a--
once in a while, there's a
pulse, like a little pulse.
That means that the
fringe are passing by.
So the reason this
is happening--
and now I will not
derive it on the paper.
Because it will end
a little bit late.
But the reason this
is happening is
because if you take the
superposition of the two
sinusoids, now we have to
be a little bit careful.
Because they have
different frequencies.
So if we use phasor--
we could use phasors.
But we might get a
little bit confused.
So for that reason, I just
wrote it in the real space
simply with cosines.
So you do the same
thing with it before.
You take the sum
of the two cosines.
You apply the
trigonometric identity
to write it as a product.
And then you find that the
product contains two terms.
One of them-- actually,
by the way, the--
oh, shoot.
There's one more
error in the notes.
There should be a cosine
between the two parentheses.
There shouldn't be a cosine.
I better write down
the correct expression.
OK, where kc equals
k1 plus k2 over 2,
and the same for omega c, and
km equals k1 minus k2 over 2,
so one of them is the average.
The other is the difference.
So now each one of those,
each one of these cosines--
OK, there's a
missing cosine here.
But imagine that
there was a cosine.
Each one of those
is a traveling wave.
So basically, what you see
now is the product of the two
traveling waves.
And you can see very
clearly it's a product here.
This is-- I have one sinusoid
of relatively low spatial period
and another sinusoid of
relatively fast spatial period.
And I multiply them.
But they're both propagating.
Because they're both of
the form kz minus omega t.
But they're propagating
with different speeds.
Because the speed of the--
oh, and-- so, what
are the names?
Well, the fast sinusoid
here is called the carrier.
Those of you who are
electrical engineers
are very familiar with those.
The carrier wave is--
in radiowaves, for example,
it is the frequency upon which
we'll modulate the signal.
And the slow sinusoid,
that's called the modulation.
And-- I lost my
train of thought.
All right, but each one of
those is a propagating wave.
So therefore, their velocities
would be equal to the--
it will depend on which
wave I'm talking about.
So, for example, the
velocity of the carrier
will equal omega of
the carrier divided
by the k of the carrier.
And the velocity
of the modulation
will equal omega
over k of the modulation.
OK, and so this is not magic.
We'll just apply the
theory that we learned.
But now it is the two
waves that are propagating.
And, of course, in general, the
two velocities are different.
Because the two
rations over here,
they have no reason
to be the same.
In fact, it is
quite the opposite.
Most of the time
they are different.
So this velocity, I actually
used a slightly different
notation.
The velocity of the carrier
is called the phase velocity.
And the velocity
of the modulation
is called the group velocity.
So the group velocity, it
equals, as you can see,
the ratio of the
difference of omega
to the ratio of the
difference of k.
So if you imagine a beat--
this is called a
beat, by the way.
I think I said it before.
So if you imagine a beat where
the two frequencies of the two
numbers are very close, then
it will become the derivative.
So the group
velocity is basically
the derivative of the--
whatever omega is
as a function of k,
if you take the derivative
of that expression,
you get the group velocity.
The phase velocity
is the same velocity
we've been talking about so
far while we're doing waves.
So there's nothing new
about the phase velocity.
It is still the ratio
of omega over k.
But the group velocity
is the derivative.
And the reason now--
ah, now the reason is revealed.
AUDIENCE: George?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
There's a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, why did
the derivative come about?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yeah, you're right.
I kind of blasted through.
So if you look at
the group velocity,
it equals omega
of the modulation
over k of the modulation.
And this equals omega
1 minus omega 2 over 2
over k1 minus k2 over 2.
That is omega 1 minus
omega 2 over k1 minus k2.
And if you take
omega one very close
but not quite the
same and k1 very close
but not quite the same, then v
sub g will become d omega dk.
So that is the reason
people put omega
on the vertical axis of it here.
Because the group
velocity, then,
is simply obtained as the slope
of the dispersion diagram.
And that's fascinating,
if you think about it.
Because it suggests
some weird things.
For example, it suggests
that if I could somehow
create this pendulum
diagram that
looks like this, what is the
strange thing about this?
That's right, it has a
negative group philosophy,
which means that in the wave,
the carrier and the modulation,
they go in opposite directions.
The phase velocity
is going to the left.
The group velocity is
going to the right.
I meant to make a movie
of this to show you.
It actually looks
a little bit weird.
But I didn't have time to do it.
And I'll show you one next time.
But now, of course, it
demands-- it's interesting.
How can you do
something like this?
It turns out to be an extremely
hot topic in optics research.
Now we know how to design,
theoretically, structures.
By the way, natural materials,
they don't have this property.
So you have to try really hard
to make this property happen,
for example, by
patterning a dielectric.
If you create patterns
in a certain way,
then you can cause--
you can make group, I
mean dispersion diagrams
that look like this.
And, of course, to
fabricate them--
you know, it is one
thing to design them
and simulate them and one
thing to fabricate them.
So these are all very hot
topics in optics research.
So that's why I--
and also, beat is sort of
a very important topic.
So that's why I spend
some time talking about.
And one of the problems--
again, in the new homework that
I posted, one of the problems
I'll get you to play a little
bit with this dispersion
relation so you can
get a feel for it.
Unfortunately, in this
class, we do mostly optics
in the space domain.
This, what I'm discussing here
is kind of time domain, right?
Because we're talking about
modulations, and carriers,
and so on.
This class is mostly
about space domain.
So we don't spend too
much time on this topic.
But anyway, it is sort
of important to know.
That's why I covered it.
With that, unless
there is any questions,
I will move on to
electromagnetics.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: George, one question.
So just now, we show that
carrier and the modulation wave
actually have
different velocity.
But in everyday
life, common sense
for [INAUDIBLE],, for
example, the red light
and the yellow light
travel at the same speed.
I mean that how
different frequency
have different wavelengths.
But the product of
these two is constant.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Not
at all, for example, we
know that is not true in glass.
That is the reason why a
prism analyzes white light.
It is because red
and yellow, they
travel with different
velocities in glass.
So any medium that
is dispersive,
they have different velocities.
AUDIENCE: So only in a vacuum
they have the same velocity.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
In vacuum, yes.
So the linear
dispersion relation
that I showed before,
that is for vacuum.
Actually, it is also
linear in a medium,
but with a different slope.
I should have said that.
COLIN SHEPPARD: I was just
going to point out that,
actually, you show
in the phase velocity
there for the free
space, not for the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
For free space, yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Yeah, but the point
where you've measured the
group velocity, that you've
labeled omega c kc, if you
drew a line from the origin
to that point, the slope of that
would give the phase velocity.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: You
are correct, actually.
Yes, yes, yes, thank you, yeah.
Yes, that's very true.
The phase velocity
is omega over k.
So it should be that one.
Yes, so I need to
correct the slides.
Thank you.
Yeah, this is the phase
velocity of free space.
COLIN SHEPPARD: And it's
greater than the speed of light.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
How could that
happen, by the way?
Because this is a
phase velocity, right?
It can do anything it wants.
It can go faster than
the speed of light.
Because it carries
no information.
It is simply an oscillation.
The group velocity, as
you will see actually--
in the homework, I get you
to derive the group velocity
for this case.
You will see from the answer
that the group velocity
is actually smaller
than the speed of light.
You will see that the group
velocity for this diagram,
it is given by something like c
square root 1 minus something.
So the group velocity
is always less than c.
OK, so I will post
the corrected version.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So would a patterned
metamaterial basically
be the same thing as a special
case of a gradient index
lens, a GRIN?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
I don't know what
you mean by a special case.
I mean, they have quite
different properties.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean you can maybe
imagine the idea of the gradient
in the dielectric material
where the gradient and
the index of refraction
sort of creating a
negative group velocity
or some case where you're
actually diverting light away
from what you're
trying to image.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I don't
think with a simple gradient
index you can--
OK, it depends on what
you mean by gradient.
If it is a slowly varying
gradient like the GRIN optics
usually, I don't think you can
create sufficient dispersion
to turn the light around.
If you have
subwavelength patterns,
then yes, because the
resulting evanescent waves
that can adapt in ways that--
yeah, I mean, this is the whole
area-- yeah, so metamaterials.
But those, usually
the gradients.
Are huge, right?
Because within a space of less
than the free space wavelength,
you might have variation
of index from 3 to 1,
and then back to 3, and so on.
So those are huge gradients.
AUDIENCE: You say
that group velocity
is the velocity with which
the information is traveling?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Well,
that's one interpretation,
yeah.
This has been challenged too.
Because people saw that
group velocity in some cases
can also exceed
the speed of light.
So therefore, even
that is questionable.
But anyway, in most
cases, group velocity
is the velocity at which
the modulation travels.
So the modulation usually
denotes information.
If you exceed the group--
if the group velocity,
if you manage to make it
exceed the speed of light,
which has been proposed,
then it means that the
modulation actually
does not carry information.
It is something that you
artificially put in there.
AUDIENCE: So why we means--
what is the advantage of
negative group velocity means
opposite direction
information travel?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Well, it can
make you a pretty
good career and get
you papers published in Nature.
No, no, I mean, there's--
I'm joking.
But [INAUDIBLE]
it is interesting.
It is interesting physics
and very counter-intuitive.
That is cool, right?
But also, the people
who work on it,
they have shown
mathematically that you
can get focusing of light
that is sometimes tighter
than traditional refractive--
you can get interesting kinds
of dispersion for pulse shaping,
very narrow--
you know, you can do some
clever things with it.
You can slow down
light, which is--
slow down light means that--
if you go back to
this diagram, you
see that as you go
towards lower frequencies,
the group velocity becomes
progressively smaller.
In fact, over here, well,
if there's a point where
it is actually 0--
so what does it mean?
Well, it means
that if you really
had the light pulse, not
the fringe of the light,
not the carrier wave, but
the envelope, the modulation,
if you were to run
into this frequency
or very close to this frequency,
that could stop, right?
It would actually-- or it
would move very, very slowly.
That's the principle of slow
light, which actually also
has potential applications.
For example, you can store data.
If you can slow light down, you
can create an optical buffer.
You can wait for something
else to happen and then launch
the wave again.
So there is things that you
can do with this in addition
to interesting physics.
It's a fascinating
topic, this one.
So I'm glad you're
asking questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and if you
go for a higher frequency,
we can see that we can excite
many modes in the waveguide.
So all the waveguides will--
it means all the modes will
have different velocity?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Which is bad, right?
Because it means that
if your information
sample split between those two
modes, then they will separate.
So they will arrive
at different times.
That is called modal dispersion.
And it is a very serious
problem in telecommunications.
It means that you get
distortion in the signal.
Was that your question,
or, I'm sorry,
I kind of answered your question
before you even asked it.
OK, here they are.
I'm sure all of you, at
some point or another,
at some moment, probably
a moment of a nightmare,
you saw them, right?
These are Maxwell's equations.
So you can read
them in the notes.
I have the two slides preceding
these where I sort drew them
in the traditional way.
And, of course, the book
also has an explanation.
But I would like to ask you if
you remember from your physics
802, those of you
who are at MIT,
or whatever it was, your basic
electromagnetics class, do you
remember each one of those,
what is it telling us,
and why does it look
the way it does?
Let's start with the first one.
Does anybody remember?
What does the first one do?
So actually, these are--
you know, these are
the same equations.
One on the left hand side
is written in integral form.
The right hand side is
written in differential form.
Does anybody want to
volunteer and say,
for example, the first row?
It is the same equation.
So what does it tell us?
AUDIENCE: The-- you want to say?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Toss a coin.
AUDIENCE: The first one
says, the integral form
says that the total electric
flux passing through a closed
surface is equal to the
total charge enclosed
inside that surface.
And the equivalent
differential form
says that the total amount of
electric field emerging out
of a point is equal to the
amount of charge at that point.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's correct.
So basically, it is telling you
that if you have a charge, then
you have field lines
radiating out of that charge.
And if you enclose this
charge with a surface
and you compute the
integral of the--
I don't know why
this is a cross.
By the way, there's
another mistake.
This should have been
a dot, not a cross.
But anyway, if you
compute this integral,
it is determined by the
total amount of charge.
OK, we can go back
to the notes now.
[INAUDIBLE]
So this is what your
colleague just said.
You have a charge.
Then you have field
lines radiating out.
And then if you take
all of these lines,
dot product them with
the elemental surface,
and then integrate, then you
get the amount of charge.
And why?
Why should it be so?
AUDIENCE: Principle of
charge conservation.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK, but why
do the field lines emanate out
of the charges?
AUDIENCE: It goes
from positive to--
I mean, it originates
from positive.
And we can say that
field line represents
the direction of the force on
a-- you need positive charge.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK,
that's what I was looking for.
So the field lines are
basically-- they tell you,
exactly like you said, what is
the direction that the small
positive charge--
let me repeat.
What is the direction
of the force
that the small
positive charge would
feel if you were to
place it at any given
position in that space?
This is what the
electric field says.
And then there is a
relationship called
Coulomb's law, which
for two given charges,
it tells you the force.
So if you have a
single charge here.
And then you apply
Coulomb's law,
then you get these
radiating lines.
So then Gauss' law is
basically nothing other
than Coulomb's law.
And yes, it also has to do
with charge conservation.
Because if you somehow
cancel all the charges
inside this volume, then
the integral will vanish.
Because it means that you
don't have any net electric--
actually, you can have
electric charge radiating.
But the integral will vanish.
In other words, if you have the
charges surrounding, somehow,
this space, the space
cannot pull them all inside.
OK, what about--
you have a question?
What about the second one?
AUDIENCE: That
means, [INAUDIBLE]
line integral is 0 means
b is a closed line.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
B is a closed line.
And b is a closed line why?
AUDIENCE: It means that
there is no magnetic charge.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
Magnets only come as dipoles.
You cannot have an isolated
north pole, for example,
of a magnet.
So actually, this is
the same equation.
In fact, they're also
known by the same name.
They're known as Gauss' law.
This type of equation,
except there's
no such thing as
magnetic charge.
What about the next one?
This one looks awful,
del cross c equals db dt.
So let's look at the integral.
Usually the differential form
is mathematically better but not
very insightful physically.
So one gets more information by
looking at the integral forms,
even though the integral
forms look really frightening.
But anyway, the third equation
is known as Faraday's law.
And it says that if you
have a viable magnetic field
inside a wire, then a potential
will develop across this wire.
And do you know of any
places where this is used?
Button.
Even I cannot hear you.
Imagine the people in Boston.
Not working?
Oh, maybe use someone else's.
OK, [INAUDIBLE], you're on.
AUDIENCE: It's
induction motors and--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah,
voice coils and generators, they
use the same principle.
So, for example, if you--
people do this in
hydroelectric plants.
You have a giant magnet.
And you somehow move a
coil inside that magnet.
And, of course, you have
to arrange it properly.
Then the coil will
develop a voltage.
So that's the principle of--
of course, you have to
move the coil, for example,
by pouring water over it,
or by steam, or whatever.
But anyway, that's the
principle of a generator.
OK, so and the last
equation that--
AUDIENCE: George,
just as an aside,
how does a nuclear power plant
generate energy, electricity?
Does it rotate something?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Actually, I don't know.
COLIN SHEPPARD: I think it just
generates steam, and then you--
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Then you
move a coil, I guess, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right, right, OK.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: And
then the last one is actually
the most interesting one.
Because this law actually was
involved with a breakthrough
in electromagnetics.
It can be known for a long time
that if you have a current,
a magnetic field develops
around that current.
That is actually Lorentz--
it is known as Lorentz force.
If you have a moving charge,
and then you put a little magnet
nearby, then the--
what am I saying.
Anyway, if you have
a moving charge,
and if you have a current,
it creates a magnetic field
around it.
That has been known
for a long time.
But what was not
known and was noticed
by Maxwell was that if
you have a capacitor--
well, in a capacitor, you can
not have a current per se.
Because the capacitor, well,
inside there's a dielectric.
So there can be no current.
But you can have
a variable charge
density in the capacitor plate.
So what I'm trying to say
is that if you apply a--
think of charge in a capacitor.
When you charge a capacitor,
the capacitor, at the beginning,
the voltage across
the capacitor is 0.
And by the time you
have totally charged it,
the voltage has
reached some value.
Well, while the
voltage is changing,
there is actually charge
flow into the capacitor.
There is a positive charge
going to the positive electrode,
then negative leaving from
the opposite electrode.
And at the same time,
what is happening,
the electric field inside
the capacitor grows.
Because as you get more charge
accumulating in the capacitor
plates, then the electric field
of the capacitor is changing.
So in a sense, you can think
of it as a current as well.
And what Maxwell-- he
guessed it, actually.
He didn't observe it.
But he guessed it.
He guessed that this kind
of variable electric field
should also generate
a magnetic field.
And the only reason he
guessed it is by symmetry
from the previous law.
What does that say?
It says that if you have
a variable magnetic flux,
you generate an
electrical potential.
Well, he looked
at this equation.
And he said, wait a minute.
It's fine that if I
have a moving charge,
I have a magnetic field.
OK, fine.
But if also I have a moving--
if I have a variable
potential, then why
should I not generate
a magnetic field?
I should.
And it turned out to be true.
I mean-- Maxwell,
by the way, he was--
do you know what
was his day job?
James Clerk Maxwell, he
was a fluid mechanic.
He was [INAUDIBLE].
And that's why the terminology--
not the terminology,
but the notation in
electromagnetic magnetics
is actually very similar to the
fluid mechanics notation, rho,
and epsilon, and all that stuff.
I mean, they're not the
same things, but the--
and also, these theorems,
the mathematical theorems,
they come from fluid mechanics.
They apply to
incomprehensible flows.
For example, the
Gauss theorem, it
applies to incomprehensible
flow in the pressure potential.
Anyway, so Maxwell
did that first.
So he guessed that you should
have this form in here.
And then he actually wrote
down all of these equations
in a coordinated form.
And the reason this was
a very valuable thing,
and I guess we're all employed
because of this [INAUDIBLE],,
is because if you manipulate
Maxwell's equations--
and I will not do it now,
because I ran out of time.
But if you manipulate
them, you can actually
show that you arrive at the
wave equation for the electric
or the magnetic field.
I did it here for
the electric field.
But you can also derive
the same equation
for the magnetic field.
So therefore, what this
means is that if you
have electric and magnetic
fields which change in time,
Maxwell's equations
tell you that they
change in a coordinated way.
And the way they change is
as an electromagnetic wave.
I think it's time to quit.
In fact, we're already
five minutes late, so.